As a very general rule, there are three types
of information that are encoded in genomes.
Probably the one that most people are
familiar with are genes that encode proteins.
But, in the human genome, this represents only
5%, or even a little less of the entire genome.
There are also regions, and nobody really
knows at present exactly where they all are
and how big they are. But we know very well
they exist and we've identified many of them
that control when genes are turned on or off and
how much. These are so-called regulatory regions.
There are 2 different parts of the regulator
regions. There are promoters that are located
just before a particular gene that regulate
gene transcription, and there are other more
mysterious parts that are called enhancers,
located far away from the gene in question.
It turns out that the enhancers, which we think of
as being very far away from the gene in question,
actually may not be so far away. That's because
up to now, we've been studying DNA and genomics in
two dimensions. But life is in three dimensions.
For a molecule of DNA, we can stretch it out,
measure it, and read it in the ways that
the modern technology allow us to do.
But that's not how it works in the body.
That's not how it works inside the cell.
The DNA molecules are coiled, and when you
look at three dimensional aspects of DNA,
you sometimes find that these enhancers that
previously, mysteriously seemed to be very far
away from the gene they are regulating, are
actually quite close by. And that's one of
the really exciting new areas, studying DNA in
three dimensions, and when you include a time
component to that, actually, four dimensions. So,
a whole new science of 4D genomics is taking shape
to understand the physical structure of a genome,
and the temporal aspects under which it functions.
The third type of important element that
you find also in all organisms, are regions,
genes that encode RNA molecules. And RNA molecules
are also essential components of every cell.
Another part has to do with parts of
the genome that aren't regulatory,
and that are not genes, and that are actually
relics of genes past. There's a lot of stretches
of the genome that don't currently or produce
any functional proteins. But yet it's still
part of a long stretch and it still gets copied
and passed down from generation to generation.
A lot of this has been referred to as junk DNA,
and there's a bit of debate about whether it's
truly junk. One of the best explanations about
it was that, don't confuse junk with trash.
Trash is useless, you throw away. Junk is what you
keep in your garage because it might one day be
useful or used to be useful and then it broke but
it's still there so you keep it. You pass it on.
So, there's a difference between junk and trash.
We think that maybe large parts of the genome,
which don't have what we think of as functional
genes in them, had been there because large
parts of the genome can get copied and put in a
different location. So, if we think about genes
as reflecting the genome as a recipe book, as
an instruction book, there's a whole other side
to the genome and that is the genome as a history
book reflecting the evolutionary history of that
particular species. This has been a marvelous area
of discovery leading to all sorts of insights,
especially but not limited to our understanding
of human evolution. We can read the genome as a